ذكريات اليمه من حرب اهليه طاحنه امتدت
سنوات لقيا طريق عودتها الى اذهان اهالي
دارفور لثالث يوم على التوالي تتواصل
اشتباكات الداميه في مدينه كتم الواقعه
على بعد 160 كيلومترا شمال غرب مدينه
الفاشر في دارفور مدينه كتم هي الاخرى
تحولت الى ساحه تجاذب للسيطره بين الدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه ففي وقت نفى الجيش
سقوط قطن في قبضه الدعم السريع اكد الاخير
عبر فيديوهات سيطره على حاميه 22 في كتب
معارك كتب تسببت بنزوح 150 الف شخص من
معسكر للنازحين باتجاه القرى المجاوره
اضافه لمقتل 54 شخصا بحسب تقديرات اوليه
كان حاكم الاقليم اعلن المنطقه منكوبه مع
استمرار اعمال النهب والقتل وقد امتدت
للشبكات لتصل الى منطقه كفود ثاني اكبر
مدينه بالمنطقه لتؤجج المخاوف من عوده شبح
حرب اهليه راقدا تحت الرماد بانتظار شراره
لايقاده فالمواجهات المسلحه التي اندلعت
عام 2003 في دارفور بين ميليشيات
الجانجويد والقوات الحكوميه ادت لمقتل 300
الف شخص وتشريد الملايين لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات